the extreme Maga Q Anon conspiracy
lunatics are turning on Marjorie Taylor
green why Marjorie Taylor green voted
for speaker Kevin McCarthy she also said
that the Q Anon stuff was just something
she fell for on the internet
so now the real hardcore Bonkers people
are Furious here are a couple callers to
the Infowars conspiracy show uh with
which Alex Jones is involved this was a
segment of calls hosted by Owen Shroyer
and people are angry with Marjorie
Taylor green now take a look at this
they are turning on her Tom in
California Tom you're on the air go
ahead go Tom
you know why I had you on speaker I
gotta work
unlike the permanent underclass they're
importing oh you have a job
that's right so well you shouldn't have
a job you big it you know what Klaus
Schwab is gonna make sure that you own
nothing
nobody hey I pay taxes so I got a
message from Marjorie Taylor Greene she
has a great
voting record but guess what it doesn't
matter when she knows that her the
policies aren't going to get through
okay so here's the only vote that counts
and that is
she needs to change her vote
today or she's a fraud okay
and she doesn't deserve to come on
Infowars if she doesn't change her vote
today Yep they're turning on her folks
the vote for McCarthy that is it here's
another caller who is all also furious
with McCarthy with Marjorie Taylor green
for voting for McCarthy Josh in Arizona
Josh you're on the Alex Jones Show go
ahead here we go hey man uh I just want
to Echo what that last guy said the one
that I had to make a quick statement
because he was going to work
um I really think that you should ask
Marjorie Taylor green if she's
compromised but they've got something on
her
divorce or something's going on with
that because you know it just kind of
seemed like there was a major flip-flop
with her it was really weird you know
like she's all this gung-ho and then
she's behind Kevin McCarthy all of a
sudden and he's on the Wes home page as
like the speaker majority I I
something's going on and I just was
wondering if you could do me a favor and
actually ask her Point Blank like do
they have something on her extreme
suspicion now of Marjorie Taylor green
the Q Anon people the Infowars people
the frogs are gay people that follow
Alex Jones
um are now turning on Marjorie Taylor
green how quickly the tide can turn but
listen obviously if you're Marjorie
Taylor green you're gonna get more power
by being friends with the speaker than
friends with the listeners of Alex Jones
Show that's an absolute uh
unquestionable reality so that is what's
happening and it's funny and sad and
scary all at the same time